j'étais pourtant persuadé d'en avoir et
claude avant françois francoual il me
manque des caramels
il faut que j'aille ont cherché tu
pourrais me garder ma boutique garder ta
boutique mais évidemment je m'en charge
73 mystique à tout à l'air tout à
l'heure je lis ça les gars bonjour julie
kuy stage est tu dois être très fatigué
après un aussi long voyage
1 alors maintenant il va falloir que tu
dormes casimir est que sais tu parle
tout seul maintenant
non je parle à mon papillon mais il est
très fatigué alors je vais le laisser
dormir je vais le mettre là didon quasi
mais c'est un papillon de quelle couleur
c'est un papillon jaune doré au il est
très beau il vient du brésil
c'est pour ça comme il il a beaucoup
volé alors il est fatigué un papillon
qui vient du brésil
ben franchement casimir j'ai jamais
entendu parler d'un insecte ayant volé
aussi l'otan mais ce n'est pas ma secte
c'est un papillon hautmont fois que j'ai
mis les papillons sont des insectes
tiens j'ai un livre sur les insectes ça
me donne l'idée d'un jeu d'accord en oui
oui très bonne idée
j'appelle les enfants les enfants venez
avec moi
venez avec moi on va faire un jeu on va
faire un jeu avec françois un jeu sur
les différents jeux sur les insectes jeu
formidable
vous êtes d'accord christophe bien bien
on y va alors les enfants on va jouer à
insectes vol quand je vous donnerai le
nom d'un insecte qui volent vous lèverez
la main et vous direz vol et quand je
dirais le nom d'un insecte qui vole pas
vous lèverez pas la main et vous dirai
rien du tout voilà tout le monde a
compris qu'elle soit facile à même
casimir c'est incompréhensible
eh bien on va voir casimir alors
abeilles habillez vous connaissez les
abeilles
on savait que les abeilles vivent
naissains il ya une mère qu'on appelle
aussi la reine qui prône des ouvrières
et des mâles un autre moustiques mâles
moustiques val exactement très
douloureux les piqûres de moustiques
faire attention
fourmies marche à une fourmi ça marche
baillet les deux effectivement j'ai des
fourmis qui marche et il y en a d'autres
qui veulent un gay 18 kg mais oui
veulent connaissez les guettent
oui c'est qu'elles ont des aiguillons
pour piquer ses feux même c'est ce que
ça qu'avoir une taille d une taille de
guêpe
c'est des mois valérie la taille très
fine casimir ce bois du tout comme toi
non pas du tout gros bond un autre vers
luisants est-ce que ça grave
un ver luisant non ça rentre si le ver
luisant justement vol on appelle ça
aussi lucioles après fallait dire
luciano et un autre le temps ah oui tout
le monde d'accord tout le monde
effectivement le temps sa valeur à nos
casimir
allez encore une sauterelle ça saute
c'est un insecte sauteur effectivement
mais il ya certaines sauterelles qui
veulent aussi donc réponse double on
continue une coccinelle
alors donc coccinelle frappe comme on
appelle aussi les coccinelles les bêtes
à bon dieu c'est joli une coccinelle 0
avec des taches noires très jolie un
autre un doryphores ça va rendre sa
valve pains doryphores
symbole comme on me françois oui
qu'est-ce que c'est un corridor ont un
sémaphore comment tu dis là un doctorat
en chimie
c'est parce que c'est un nom un
doryphores c'est un insecte très
nuisible un petit insecte qui mangent
des plants de pommes de terre par bon
c'est quoi ça ressemble non et bien
c'est comme une grosse coccinelle c'est
jaune et sa des rayures noires 54
délicieux avec de la glace à la fraise
on va sur toi pour toi certainement
casimir bon un autre les ensembles un
pou savalou savall par épouser un pou
non non ça vole pas c'est ce que ça
qu'un peu c'est un insecte parasite qui
est ingrate qui gratte
agathe oui effectivement les chiens ont
quelquefois et d'autres animaux bien une
puce
c'est pareil agathe ça saute
effectivement et c'est comme le tout
d'ailleurs
la puce offre sa gratte fort on continue
un autre une libellule
vous savez comment on appelle aussi la
libellule une règle en famille
anne-christine aussi un autre front
l'eau c'est une grosse guerre d'offres
low mais dis moi où il connaît tous les
insectes mais dont casimir y en a
beaucoup trop tu sais casimir une
question à ton avis combien d'espèces
d'insectes différentes
y at-il dans le monde droit c'est facile
alors départ il y en a 14 ans y en a
plus y en a moins d eau fort allez on
est cinq ans pas plus ou moins casimir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plaint
sentent encore mille les enfants de la
télé c'est pas possible et pourquoi
c'est pas possible que je ne fais pas
compter au delà de 1000 et bien pourtant
casimir il y en a beaucoup plus de 1000
combien les enfants
à votre avis combien d'espèces
d'insectes différentes
y at-il dans le monde réponde et chercha
tu sais la cheminée la réponse est bien
en réalité personne ne connaît le
chiffre exact mais d'après les savants
il y aurait plus d'un million d'espèces
d'insectes différentes dans le monde
c'est évidemment un nom vous faites à
j'ai accueilli un jeu sur les insectes
tu as trouvé tes caramel oui ils ont
l'air fab
puis l'avion avait conduit ces boîtes
noires
julie attention mon papillon je suis sûr
que tu l'a réveillé mais je ne savais
pas que j'avais un papillon qui
dormaient dans cette nuit dit il est
très beau il vient du brésil
casimir maintenant qu'il est réveillé je
peux le voir ton papillon papillon qui
vient du brésil où il est il est jaune
doré regarde il a l'air très fatigué ou
moussa kazim et regarder mais quasi mais
quoi mais c'est papillon ça c'est une
bonne de terre chips
oui mon papillon une chips mais oui les
enfants c'est un papillon ça tu vois
casimir c'est une chips [ __ ] pense
aussi julie je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
doute malheureusement j'ai regardé émir
je vais même l'abroger ça alors alors je
me suis trompé mais c'est incroyable
j'ai vraiment pris cette pomme de terre
chips pour un papillon je suis vraiment
mieux mais non il arrive à tout le monde
de ce temps baissé mais tu sais moi
aussi j'avais prise quant à papillons
mais alors il y a quelque chose que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce qui te répète que aigner
et bien comment est-ce que cette pomme
de terre chips un peu voler du brésil
jusqu'ici
[Musique]